-Elle s'est lancée dans la bataille
des législatives au dernier moment,
mais elle maîtrise parfaitement
les codes de la politique,
pour l'avoir observée
pendant longtemps.
Un savoir-faire précieux
qu'elle a mis au service
de Marine Le Pen,
son amie de 25 ans.
Générique
...
-Bonjour, Caroline Parmentier.
-Bonjour, Clément.
-En 2018,
Marine Le Pen est venue
vous embaucher, en quelque sorte.
Vous étiez journaliste,
à l'époque.
Elle vous a demandé de vous occuper
des relations presse
du parti et surtout des siennes.
Votre rôle ne s'est pas limité
à cela.
Pendant 5 ans,
vous avez fait
un gros travail sur son image.
Ca s'est traduit notamment
par un nouveau genre de vidéos,
postées par Marine Le Pen
sur les réseaux sociaux.
*Musique douce
*-T'es bien, là ? Hein ?
*...
Tranquille !
Mon arbre !
Mon arbre ! Allez, sors !
Sors ! Oh, biquette.
*Musique folklorique
*...
Marine Le Pen chante.
-La vidéo qu'on vient de voir
avec le chat
de Marine Le Pen
coincé dans le sapin de Noël
a quand même fait 4,4 millions
de vue sur TikTok.
Il y a rien de politique.
Ca fait quand même partie
de la politique, selon vous ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
J'ai toujours trouvé...
J'avais envie que les Français
connaissent Marine Le Pen
comme moi je la connaissais,
c'est-à-dire riante, chantante,
ayant trois enfants.
Il y a beaucoup de choses
dans sa vie
que les Français ne connaissent pas
du tout.
Ils la voient comme une femme
derrière un pupitre,
lors des meetings
ou des plateaux télévisés,
mais je voulais
qu'ils se rendent compte
de qui elle était.
Ca a été un peu tout l'enjeu
de cette campagne présidentielle
2022,
que les journalistes, d'abord,
que les photographes, ensuite,
que les Français sachent
qui est Marine Le Pen réellement.
-Il y a eu cet aspect-là
sur les réseaux sociaux,
mais il n'y a pas eu que cela.
Dans le même registre,
on a vu Marine Le Pen
parler de ses chats
et de sa colocataire
face à Karine Le Marchand,
on l'a vue évoquer
la rupture avec son père
dans une émission,
face à Cyril Hanouna,
"Face à Baba",
on l'a vue dans une interview
avec Magali Berdah,
sur YouTube.
On a longtemps parlé
de dédiabolisation
du Rassemblement National.
Fallait-il dédiaboliser
Marine Le Pen,
ou en tout cas la normaliser ?
-Marine Le Pen est aussi
une Française comme vous et moi.
C'est quelque chose qui me frappe
quand je suis avec elle.
C'est quelqu'un de simple,
qui a un contact direct
avec les gens, qui a de l'empathie.
Les habitants de sa circonscription
du Pas-de-Calais le savent bien.
Il était important, en effet,
que les Français la voient comme ça.
-On connaît le slogan
de Paris Match :
"Le poids des mots,
le choc des photos."
Ca pourrait presque être
votre devise à vous aussi.
Concernant le choc des photos,
vous vous êtes insurgée
contre les photos choisies
par certains journaux pour illustrer
leurs articles consacrés
à Marine Le Pen.
Ca veut dire quoi ?
Elles traduisaient un parti pris
politique, selon vous ?
-Ce n'était pas
des photos honnêtes.
Quand je suis arrivée
au Rassemblement National
en 2018,
après que Marine m'ait débauchée,
les photos...
On avait coutume de voir
des photos de Marine
où elle était moche,
où elle était parfois affreuse,
prise par en dessous,
elle faisait peur.
Je pense que l'idée,
c'était ça, d'ailleurs.
Vous savez comme moi que la plupart
des gens regardent la photo,
lisent le titre de l'article,
et puis c'est tout, parfois.
Donc j'ai commencé par parler
aux photographes en leur disant :
"C'est vous qui avez pris
cette photo ?
"Vous rentreriez chez vous
avec une photo, comme ça,
"de votre femme, de votre épouse,
de votre belle-mère ?
"Vous seriez curieusement reçu."
J'ai parlé aux rédactions, aussi.
Je leur ai dit
que c'était plus possible,
ça me paraissait pas juste.
Elle était jolie, blonde,
elle avait minci.
Je ne voulais pas qu'elle apparaisse
comme ça.
-Pour le poids des mots,
vous avez décidé de reprendre
systématiquement
les journalistes
qui qualifient le RN
de parti d'extrême droite.
C'est une bataille sémantique
que vous avez d'ailleurs menée
avec un certain succès.
Est-ce que c'est pas
une remise en cause
de la liberté de la presse ?
-Il faut être juste
et il faut être honnête, aussi.
Le Rassemblement National
et Marine Le Pen
ne correspondent en aucun cas
à l'extrême droite,
à cette qualification.
On connaît la définition
de l'extrême droite :
antiparlementarisme,
contestation des résultats
électoraux...
C'est absolument pas ça.
J'ai trouvé
que c'était une injustice.
J'en ai parlé avec l'AFP,
notamment.
-C'est un combat
que Jean-Marie Le Pen avait mené
en son temps, bien avant vous,
au point qu'en 1996,
la justice a estimé que l'emploi
du qualificatif d'extrême droite
par Libération et Le Monde
relevait de la liberté d'opinion,
d'analyse et de jugement
d'un journal.
-D'ailleurs,
ils ont continué à le faire.
-Vous-même,
vous avez pratiqué une forme
de journalisme engagé,
on va en parler.
Vous auriez accepté
qu'un parti politique vous impose
une façon précise de le qualifier ?
-Non, mais j'aurais écouté
ce qu'il avait à me dire.
Mon idée n'était pas
de les persuader,
de les obliger,
mais d'en discuter avec eux
et qu'ils m'expliquent pourquoi.
Ca n'était plus justifié.
Lorsque j'étais journaliste,
j'aurais été ravie de parler
avec un homme politique de ça,
ou avec un attaché de presse.
Ca fait partie du métier, aussi,
de discuter
et d'échanger sur ses vues.
-Vous allez me reprendre,
si je dis que vous avez travaillé
pour un journal
d'extrême droite ?
-Je récuse cette appellation
pour mon journal aussi.
-Vous avez fait
toute votre carrière
au journal Présent,
que lisaient vos parents.
Ils votaient pour le Front National.
Ils étaient sympathisants
ou ils étaient engagés ?
-Ils étaient sympathisants.
-Vous êtes arrivée comme stagiaire,
à 21 ans,
et vous êtes restée 31 ans.
C'était un journal sur une ligne
proche des milieux catholiques
traditionnalistes.
Pour vous, le journalisme
devait forcément traduire
un engagement ?
Il fallait défendre des idées ?
Des valeurs ?
-Oui. Le journalisme
d'opinion m'intéressait.
J'y ai tout de suite vu l'occasion
aussi,
- comme quoi,
il y a quand même un lien -
de suivre le Front National
et le Rassemblement National.
Ca a été ma fonction, en effet,
d'aller dans tous les meetings,
de les interviewer,
dans le plus de conférences
de presse possible.
Ce petit journal
n'avait pas beaucoup de moyens.
C'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré
Marine Le Pen,
que je ne connaissais pas.
-On va évoquer ça dans un instant.
Quelles sont vos idées, vos valeurs,
que vous avez voulu défendre,
à travers ce journalisme d'opinion,
comme vous dites ?
-Alors, quand j'étais journaliste,
encore une fois,
je n'écrivais pas que
sur la politique.
J'ai fait beaucoup
de chroniques cinéma.
A une époque,
j'allais au cinéma tous les jours.
J'écrivais également sur la police.
Et effectivement,
sur le Rassemblement National,
pour le coup,
je me suis tout de suite reconnue
dans les idées de Marine Le Pen,
parce qu'elle aimait la France
et elle aimait les Français.
Pour moi, l'engagement politique,
c'est de défendre
la France et les Français,
loin des grandes envolées,
des joutes verbales,
ou des leçons d'histoire
à la sauvette.
Je pense que les Français
attendent des hommes politiques
qui les défendent
dans leur quotidien
et qu'ils améliorent
leur vie quotidienne, voilà.
-Ce travail de journaliste
vous a permis
de rencontrer Marine Le Pen,
à l'occasion de la fête BBR,
tous les ans,
"Bleu, blanc, rouge",
la fête du Front National.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a rapprochées,
toutes les deux ?
-Je l'ai tout de suite trouvée
sympathique,
drôle, grande gueule,
fine dans ses analyses politiques,
on avait 2 ans d'écart d'âge,
finalement,
ce qui n'est pas beaucoup,
on était toutes les deux divorcées,
on avait toutes les deux trois
enfants des mêmes âges.
Ce sont des choses qui font
qu'on peut se reconnaître.
Elle avait la gentillesse de me dire
qu'elle m'avait suivie
dans certains articles.
Je l'avais énormément suivie.
En 2011, quand elle est arrivée
à la tête du parti
Rassemblement National,
il y a eu une scission,
dans mon journal,
dans mon petit journal,
entre ceux qui voulaient rester
proche de Jean-Marie Le Pen,
qui trouvaient que Marine
n'était pas l'avenir,
et moi,
qui voulais que ce soit Marine.
On s'est bien battues,
ça a été assez ardu.
Je suis devenue rédactrice en chef.
Voilà.
-Ca correspond
à un certaine réalité.
Pendant vos années de journalisme,
vous avez parfois semblé
être politiquement
plus proche d'Eric Zemmour
ou de Marion Maréchal...
-Qui existaient peu, à l'époque.
-...que de Marine Le Pen.
Vous l'avez critiquée
quand elle a écarté son père
de l'organigramme du parti.
-Très exactement...
Avez-vous vraiment l'article
sous les yeux ?
-Pas sous les yeux, non.
-Je ne l'ai pas critiquée.
Des journalistes l'ont dit.
Il m'est arrivé de la critiquer.
J'ai dit
qu'elle n'avait pas le choix,
que c'était terrible,
que c'était horriblement pénible,
pour une fille, pour nous tous,
qui avions beaucoup de respect
pour Jean-Marie Le Pen,
mais qu'elle n'avait pas le choix.
Sinon, ce serait sans fin.
-Est-ce que ce n'est pas l'amitié,
plus que la politique,
qui vous a poussée à vous engager
aux côtés de Marine Le Pen ?
-Quand elle m'a demandé
de travailler pour elle,
j'ai été prise d'une angoisse.
Ce n'est pas mon métier,
d'être attachée de presse.
J'avais peur de faire des erreurs,
voilà.
C'est par amitié pour elle
que je suis venue,
mais par passion, aussi,
de ce qu'allait être
cette formidable aventure politique.
Ca l'a été et ça continue de l'être.
Travailler auprès de Marine Le Pen
à la présidentielle
est exceptionnel.
Je souhaite à tout le monde
de vivre cette aventure-là.
-Votre candidature aux législatives
s'est faite
après le second tour
de la présidentielle.
Qu'est-ce qui vous a convaincue
de passer de l'autre côté du miroir,
de devenir une femme politique ?
-Le fait d'avoir suivi Marine.
Je l'ai suivie
dans le Pas-de-Calais.
Elle était députée
dans la circonscription
du Pas-de-Calais.
Je voyais ce que les gens
lui disaient.
Je l'ai suivie peut-être 10 fois,
12 fois, dans le Pas-de-Calais,
dans le cadre de mon métier.
Je voyais ce que les gens
avaient à lui dire,
ce que les habitants
du Pas-de-Calais
lui disaient
et ce qu'elle leur répondait.
Je me suis dit que je pouvais
leur apporter quelque chose,
que je pouvais travailler pour eux,
et que je serais une députée
qui essaierait
de tenir ses promesses
et qui, encore une fois,
les aiderait dans leur vie
quotidienne.
-On va finir par un quiz,
un peu différent de d'habitude,
un quiz spécial Ch'tis,
parce que vous avez été investie
aux législatives
dans le Pas-de-Calais,
mais vos attaches
étaient en région parisienne.
L'idée est de savoir
si vous vous êtes acclimatée
à cette région.
On commence
par une spécialité locale.
De quoi s'agit-il ?
-Le potch !
-Oui !
-J'adore !
-Vous avez abrégé le nom.
C'est le potjevleesch.
-Oui.
Habituellement, on dit "potch".
-Vous connaissez la recette ?
-C'est trois viandes en gelée :
lapin, porc, veau.
C'est très bon
avec une salade
et c'est excellent avec des frites
au maroilles.
-Si je vous dis : "Wassingue" ?
-Euh... Oui...
Alors là, vous me posez une colle.
-Ah !
-Bien joué !
Aidez-moi.
-On va la voir en image.
C'est la serpillère, en Ch'ti.
-Très bien.
-C'était une question-piège.
-Je la passe peu.
-On termine par une comptine
célèbre dans la région.
A vous de la compléter.
"Dors, min p'tit quinquin,
"min p'tit..."
-Le beffroi de Béthune
la joue régulièrement.
Dors min p'tit quinquin
Min p'tit... Min p'tit...
-Et entre les deux ?
"Min p'tit pouchin,
"min gros rojin."
"Mon petit poussin,
"mon gros raisin."
Je traduis.
-Parfait.
Notez que j'ai su la fredonner.
-Parfait !
-Merci d'être venue.
-C'est moi qui vous remercie.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA